one of the things that people make a
mistake on is they're like oh I'm
getting 700 views per post now when I
was doing five days a week I was doing
500 posts I'm like right but one is 2500
views and one's 2100 views if you go
three times seven versus five times five
the other thing is what I really want
for all of you is to get to the content
that does well to inform your content
going forward so I'm less worried about
how well each individual piece goes for
all of you I want you to take more at
bats to be better at it so right now
what's happening is too many people are
trying to be cute and like higher
quality less quantity deep down because
it's easier because it's work it's hard
you got other things I get it I'm not
judging but I'm trying to tell everybody
you're all trying to get better at
tennis and if you practice five days a
week instead of three days a week you'll
be better at tennis in 24 months one of
the things I'm concerned about is when
people go with that model is they're not
doing enough pieces of content to figure
out the thing that's going to work if I
wasn't posting as often I don't know if
I would have gotten into a lot of the
content I got into because I wouldn't
have the feedback loop from all the
content